[Music]
[Applause]
luna the fastest easiest way to buy
bitcoin
if you're just getting into crypto it's
the perfect place to start
hey guys and welcome back to the lehigh
pen show
powered by icon plus capital the vc firm
so joining me today is a really exciting
guest it is
sean culkin the nfl tight end
who said that he is going to turn his
entire salary
into bitcoin sean welcome to the show
how are you
hey thanks so much for having me i'm
doing great good to be here
yeah it's really good to have you um
before we jump in i do just want to say
a quick thank you to all my sponsors
because if it wasn't for them this
wouldn't be possible
um so this is um sponsored by block fi
you can actually get amazing interest
rates on your crypto your
stable coins whatever it is and there is
a description for you somewhere
and this month it's actually um
sponsored by coin um by compass mining
sorry so compass mining are really
interesting
they're actually the company that makes
bitcoin mining accessible for
everyone you just buy your machine pick
a hosting facility and let them do the
work so
if you do want to start mining some
bitcoin then head to compassmining.io
it's really cool because mining bitcoin
right now is pretty impossible
so there you go so thank you to them so
sean
welcome to the show i've been so excited
to speak to you the first thing actually
i wanted to ask you
is can you explain to me what a tight
end is because i'm english and like i
don't know any of this stuff
yeah sure sure so uh let's start with uh
offense and defense so tight ends on
offense and
it's kind of a combination of a receiver
who has to catch the ball
and an offensive lineman who is like
bigger guys that are blocking
protecting the quarterback or creating
holes for the running back so a tight
end is somebody
that pretty much has to do both so
they're pretty um
very multi-dimensional have to know the
run game the pass game
i like to think they're the smartest
guys on the field the most versatile but
it's fun because
yeah you got to be fast but then you
have to be strong yeah i feel like that
kind of
represents what i know of you so far you
seem to be quite
diverse i know that you have a finance
background which we'll get into but
um before we do i'd love to know a
little bit more about you
personally um your background where you
come from
um i'd love to hear it all yeah yeah so
i'm from indian rocks beach florida
it's about 30 minutes south from tampa
and i was born and raised
there my whole life i have one brother
who pretty much i pretty much tried to
do everything he did growing up he ran
track played football and basketball
those are the three sports i did and
just over time i initially was a
basketball
prospect i kind of thought that was my
path uh to collegiate sports and
my senior year i decided to play
football in college because i kind of
just had
more of the mentality to get bigger and
stronger and
i also in six five and basketball
nowadays you have to be like six eight
did you say you're six five
yeah six five six five damn that's
insane
but that's awesome but that's so short
for basketball
yeah i know yeah i was the shortest guy
on my team my uh
i was on adidas team for florida and i
was one of the shortest
guys and i kind of saw the writing on
the wall and um
just all more of a you know more of a
upside in football so i went to
university of missouri
and that was the first year they were in
the sec
and that was a really cool experience
and from there
just uh yeah kind of like as you said i
i
started studying finance i realized that
football could end at any point in time
i tore my mcl
and luckily it wasn't anything serious
but i knew that injuries do occur in the
sport
and i don't want to look back and
reflect on my time in college getting a
free education
and not take advantage of that so i
switched to finance and just fell in
love with it immediately it was the
first time where i had a passion
equivalent to my interest in football
and
just immersed myself in the readings and
understanding
the lectures and kind of was using
football to
uh almost set up a career after football
like and i know
at one time i wanted to do wall street
so i was
yeah yeah so i was you know i was uh
an equity research analyst for an
insurance firm
and sitting on bloomberg crunching excel
spreadsheet numbers and
um handling the endowment money for the
business school and
just and studying for the cfa level one
so i'm going like 80 90 hours a week
yeah on top of being a d1 athlete and
figured you know
whenever football ends i'm already ready
for that and
through just over time i slowly just
navigated more and more to bitcoin
i think that is um i think that's really
important you mentioned having a backup
plan
but i i see it's not so much a backup
plan because i think backup plans have
really bad connotations it's kind of
like i'll have that in case i fail so
it's not i don't mean it like that
it's more like life is so unpredictable
and you know there's so many different
things that can happen to you
um not even just you you know just like
circumstances like let's just say covert
as an example so many people's
businesses you know
just kind of totally went to rubbish
unfortunately
um so you fell in love with finance what
about it did you fall in love with
that's really interesting
just uh intricacies and complexity of
just
the markets and how they all are
intertwined i thought it was just
fascinating how
everything um was linked there's just so
much to learn right
and i love the i think it's also
important to note that my dad was a gold
bug
so i was already exposed to that
contrarian view
as well growing up on the central bank
fallacies and
the concept of money and questioning you
know fiat systems and
um so between that and then what i was
doing for my internship
the um the studies that i had in college
it just
there's just so much material to learn
and once i'm um
just completely committed to something i
just obsess over it and i want to
try to understand everything so
that was really it just just the amount
of dense information available in the
ratings
and obviously you can make money you
know through
at one point i even tried to dabble with
day trading and realize that that's yeah
that's not
it's a it's too it's too much time um it
required so
i just like that stress yes too much
stress my emotions are involved
i've never yeah yeah it's not not worth
it so
um and then yeah this is good
yeah no i'm just gonna say so like so
you obviously your dad had a gold
background which is really interesting
and we'll get to that but like
given that you studied finance did you
feel when you came across bitcoin that
suddenly you had to unlearn everything
you had learned
eventually at some point i had to just
rethink through things yes
in a way unlearn yes of course which i
think that
is important you know for for success i
think you sometimes have to
look back on history and your upbringing
and what was taught
and just question and and think for
yourself
i think is the most powerful thing any
individual can do so
bitcoin definitely aided in that process
of just
going back and questioning things and
reading
and understanding and thinking for
myself deciding for myself on
what i think is the best store of value
for my wealth
and i think that's um you know at some
point in time
any person that's with high conviction
in bitcoin has probably had to go
through that path
yeah i think the you make a really
interesting point because
that is one of the best things about
bitcoin in that it encourages you to
question what you've already learned and
there are so many
narratives that are just shoved down our
throats i mean even inflation is an
example i've never seen
so much pro-inflation media recently um
right you know it is
and we're just almost told to accept it
you know you just accept what you're
told yeah um and and
cpi is the best reflection of inflation
right like
like the idea of that i that was quick
for me just in talking to my dad
and just seeing how you know the compute
the cpi
it didn't necessarily make sense and
then early on when i started
you know listening to sailor and how he
talked about yeah inflation being kind
of
linked to the lifestyle that you want
right what are you trying to buy
like what kind of life style are you
trying to live and provide for your
family
kind of dictates also your inflation
bracket in a way
and if you're just sitting at home
and you know staying at your parents and
not paying rent and
um you know just watching netflix all
day like inflation's not too bad you
know that's the example that he used but
if you're trying to
buy a home and eventually have kids and
send them to
university for education and healthcare
it's like well inflation's quite high
yeah it is and it it just we were
talking obviously earlier and now we
were talking about my book and
and everything that i have coming out
and like i'm i'm writing about inflation
and when i saw this pro media
sorry this media um pro-inflation
um content coming out from the media i
was upset
like i was hurt you know i just i'm just
there like talking about
how um you know my grandfather was able
to do this
and now we have to work double to be
able to even almost do that
and yeah the same day you've got
inflation could be good there's a silver
lining because you know salaries are
going up
it doesn't work like that it doesn't
work like that and unfortunately i think
people
just because of you know their lives
people are busy right
and unless you take the time to allocate
learning more
you see a headline and then you just
move on with your day and they already
have this
conception of okay well inflation maybe
is good i don't know oh wages are
increasing i'm sure that's all true and
they go on
and they don't know and understand that
you're demanding more of my time and
resources to consume
the same amount of goods and or do the
same and consume less
and once people understand that and just
the
relationship of time and money
then that's when you kind of
just eventually inevitably right that's
what we all say gratitude towards
bitcoin
yeah i mean it's all of it though
because like it for me it's just
it's not bitcoin in general it's kind of
like this slave mentality
i feel that we're taught um in that
um you know
trading time for dollars like that's a
big one
and that's something that everybody
feels that they have to do and you
actually don't
right a salary right yeah yeah yeah yes
it goes back to rich dad poor dad
philosophy i've been
yeah seeing him pop up a lot lately on
my just you know the instagram reels and
everything and yeah
you know he talks about just as soon as
you take a salary and unfortunately
there's you know people that
where they like to drive or just um
direction and
you know and how to provide financially
for themselves or their family
in other ways like you know it's a good
way of making a living but there's it's
not the only way
and once you start to stop working for
money
unless you're your money worked for you
that's the ultimate um solution for
for success yeah and i feel like bitcoin
is wrapped into all of that and we'll
get to it but i was tweeting actually
yesterday about how the nine to five is
a scam
and i got a lot of backlash for it right
and i don't mean it straight up i get
that obviously some people
have a nine to five everybody's
different it's whatever suits
but for me that's not the issue it's
that
you're just not in this day and age with
inflation you're just not going to
retire
in the way that you deserve to retire by
the time you deserve to retire
yeah i think yeah because the 9-5 was
accustomed to
gosh you know the fed fund rate being so
high right at some point you could place
your money and fix income and get 15
or to place it in a cd and get five
percent and
you know you had only had to work nine
to five for x amount of years and
then you retired and you lived happily
and and unfortunately
i don't know if that's the case like
that's what i said early on um and when
i made this decision it's like
regardless of your views on bitcoin
like just overall you look at the
current economic environment like
what asset class right now do you trust
to provide
um a positive real real yield right so
uh for me obviously i think the
asymmetric trade that bitcoin offers is
unparalleled to any other asset
and but yeah it's it's quite sad i mean
the stat too also it's you know if you
had a million dollars
pre-1971 i think it was in 1971 now you
need like i think it's like 6.5 million
dollars
to have the same equivalent purchasing
power and that's
i mean that's crazy that's you know over
50 years
and you know and that's just in the u.s
if you look at globally you know people
are experiencing inflation rates that
are what are exciting way faster than
the u.s
rights are right it's it's it's really
sad honestly and that's i think that's
also why
you know this the everyone says bitcoin
is hope that's what we
mean it's hope it's sound money it's
available to all it's not just domestic
it's it's a global play yeah absolutely
and like just even outside of finance
just
with i'm a very political person so just
like with everything that's going on
geopolitically right now i i find
comfort and peace in bitcoin and that it
is
opting out of the system but with all of
that in mind that how did you first hear
about bitcoin
yeah so kind of funny story i was
when i was an equity research analyst at
the time i remember uh
the firm had a subscription to bloomberg
magazine and they would just sit on the
desk and i remember
just having a little bit of a break and
grabbed the magazine and
i just they started talking about
blockchain satoshi nakamoto this
anonymous
creator of this peer-to-peer electronic
payment system and
it just i quickly could link it to gold
that was something that i i started to
digest
but unfortunately it was i think five
days
it was like at the end of my summer
internship before camp started my last
year
at mizzou and once that started yeah
yeah yeah so
once it starts it's like 5am to 9pm
for 30 days and then you start the
regular season so as we all know i think
unless you have skin in the game unless
you put capital into it like you're
probably going to forget forget about it
you're not going to be
invested personally emotionally to learn
more
and unfortunately i think the price was
750 at the time
but that was my first exposure to it but
never bought it
and just over time i think it's also
important to note that i was teammates
with russell [ __ ]
with the la chargers for three years so
we would have
really good conversations just in the
training room
locker room just in between meetings and
i always appreciated
his contrarian view um that a lot of
bitcoiners have right so
that was the beginning process where
okay like it just
it makes a little bit more sense at
first i kind of couldn't get over the
volatility of it
i think as a lot of people do and
because you're kind of thinking oh well
it's supposed to be just a currency and
i think once you start to see there's
levels to it where
how about store value let's start soar
value there and then let's see
once adoption happens once um
you know the price kind of stabilizes as
it gets appreciates the whole
bitcoinization aspect if that happens
like over time
then it's definitely going to be used as
a you know currency i could definitely
see that happening but
it's it's it could be okay
it's volatile but then there's how many
countries out there right now that don't
even have
opportunity to be banked and have any
type of currency that's not
being deflated away at 15 month over
month right
so once you started thinking like that
then it just made me want to
really dive in and learn more and just
through time
my conviction grew but it really
didn't get to the level of where it is
now until like november 2020
i march 2020 was a big time i started to
learn more about it but
i was also just coming off an achilles
surgery
um that was so i was pretty much putting
all my time just trying to get healthy
and back to get back on
a team and then once i signed with the
ravens i spent last year with them
and once i had a little bit of an injury
on my ankle i was out for a few weeks
had some more time on my hands
mid-season
and that's when bitcoin was starting to
pop off and
just bought some learned more and then
it's been you know that's
that's all she said right it's it's been
i've been completely obsessed since then
no it's good i love it um perfect timing
as well but
you mentioned that it reminded you of
gold which is really interesting your
dad's a gold bug
so so tell me the train of thought
do you think i mean you didn't go and
put a bunch of money into gold i mean i
don't know if you did
you put it into bitcoin it sounds like
so how did you weigh up the difference
between bitcoin and gold like what sold
you on bitcoin over gold
i'm assuming you're sold on bitcoin over
gold yeah i think
if you look at stock to flow it's
superior it's better it's more
transparent
this issue is right like what are the
asset class do you
just know exactly what the protocol is
going to be like for that
the next 100 years um
i liked how like technology
wasn't in the game when for for gold to
last 5 000 years right like that's such
a big
um you know that's such a long period of
time
but short in terms of just the existence
of the world right
and when you start to introduce
technology
and what the effect of that is and what
you see going on with blockchain
utilization and then now bitcoin and
then the layer two
and then younger generations wanting to
you know use it and adopt it yeah
question fiat that's becoming
a popular topic right
if you just kind of extrapolate that
going forward like what is the use case
for gold
like i don't know many people that are
just wow i can't wait to get a gold
necklace
like i can't wait to use gold like i
just don't
i love gold necklaces
but it just seemed like it was inferior
in every category
yeah and other than track record and
this isn't
two years three years this is 12 years
still short in comparison to gold but
if you see what if you take a step back
and just see
um just what's being built the
infrastructure the amount of
resources and how it's becoming
political now
and you see that trend it's a i just i
see um
capital influx definitely leaving gold
and going into
bitcoin i mean so like
the gold thing is so interesting to me
um because i'm totally with you when it
comes to the use case like i love a good
gold necklace but that's about it
there's not much i can't really hold my
wealth in this little necklace here so
totally with you um but it's interesting
because
um bitcoin is so hard to sell to the
older generation
um especially um sorry especially over
gold
but i feel like um millennials
the next gen z i feel like it's such an
obvious sell
um you know when it comes to portability
and so many different things the use
cases of it um
it's also fun like i know that might
sound kind of weird
but i do find it fun yeah um
you know yeah absolutely it's it's
definitely i think
i mean other than uh that that the
dynamic of the shift
um you know family it's like what
no one's there there's no gold twitter
right that no
you know um it's
it's just different i i i think you're
at the front of a revolution right like
you're at the front of a revolution
is incredible um but does your dad get
on board with bitcoin
given he's a gold bag it's uh it's it's
it's been
easy because of his
you know attractive uh what he finds
attractive in gold
but then there's also that hurdle of him
just being older
right he's i think now 71 so
sometimes he just will get it and i
think it's so close and then
boom he'll like have this question but
he's starting to understand it
um he's definitely wait what's his
question like where does he get stuck on
uh usually energy uh okay
and then just i think just
the volatility in a way when you look at
on a short-term perspective
how does that equate to a store of value
but then
i think it just takes it takes a lot of
research and conviction
to zoom out and just not be
stomach by volatility in the short term
any way possible right like i think if
you just look at it
a lot of people unfortunately they're so
emotionally involved when it comes to
money
so when it's going like this it's you
know some people don't have
unique conviction i think to just be
okay with that
and it takes time and he i don't he
hasn't put the time other than
a couple articles he's probably
researched on his own and the
conversations that we've had but he
needs more but he's definitely coming
around
he'll be orange killed before 2022 for
sure oh i love that that's cool no i
totally understand
um my dad has been a finance for years
um he's not like a gold bug but he's in
finance so he gets
the situation um and when tesla put um
their 1.5 or 1.6 i can't remember
billion
um into bitcoin i told my dad and his
first response was
okay you're gonna sell now i'm like no
now is when we hold really hard
i was like no this is when we hold
really tight i was like if we're getting
money from these kind of people then you
know it's it's incredible but you make a
point it is becoming so
political um and a lot of people say
that it's a political
for a million reasons i think it is
political but that's another debate for
another time but
it's really interesting what's happening
with el salvador um
there's so much hostility um
from so many different places countries
governments
organizations institutions um
i think it's so sad because like the
country is just trying to
make a better life for everyone by
trying something new
yeah no exactly i think it's unfortunate
that i think they could link you know
maybe it's um
crime rate and just previous you know
history when it comes to el salvador
and just extrapolate that to like what
the situation at hand is now
and like you don't know that right like
it's like
i'm glad that peter mccormack could sit
down with him and
understand and have a conversation
because they're just trying to do the
right thing and provide hope to the
people
and it's unfortunate that some people
can't wrap their minds around that
um but to your point like i think it
definitely will become political it's
starting to happen now and i think that
will
continue for um the you know foreseeable
future but at some point i do think it
transcends politics
like from my um experience i've never
been in a room where i could sit down
with like a hard
right conservative in the very left
liberal
and usually you're never going to come
and see eye to eye right like you're
always going to either not say what you
really want to say or it's going to go
to a
you know really elevated argument and
i've been in the rooms where i've
introduced bitcoin and the concept
of it and it is pretty remarkable how
there's some common ground there i i
think like i guess where the light
you know the light kind of clicked for
me where it's like okay
this is something that i think
transcends politics like maybe i
socially it's like i see um you know
what maybe
uh democrats and liberals would want to
introduce and i'm like man i i
definitely see the reform and need
for that because it's sadness um you
know there's situations like that
but then let's talk about the solution
right like is it expanding the money
supply at even a higher rate is that
what's better for those
marginalized groups where the more
position the more wealth that you have
stored in cash
like the more honestly you need bitcoin
and it's hard right now because
unfortunately this is the way life works
sometimes you know
those um individuals don't have
disposable income to this put in bitcoin
that
can they don't need it for the long term
right they might need it in the short
term and the volatility is something
that needs to be explained to them
and they need to do their own research
but i would like to think that if they
don't need it at least for
you know obviously i would like to think
10 plus years for long term investment
but
at least like a four or five year you
know cycle i truly believe
bitcoin is it's it's it's it's hope
you know even more for those people that
get benefit from the appreciation
and the fact it's not going to be
deflated away yeah i think
it is something which can definitely
bring both sides together but i only
feel that way to an extent
um because i don't know where you form
the political spectrum but my
um my audience know where i fall i'm
very much
like i i'd be a republican if i was
american basically
i'd really enjoy texas let's just
believe it
but um but i just i just sort of feel
that
a a sort of left wing or a democratic
mentality would be to have more control
less freedom um you know more government
intervention
more regulation just more involvement i
just feel like bitcoin is just like
from a philosophical from a
philosophical standpoint really anti
that you know
it is yeah no you bring up a good point
because you know i kind of i'm just
talking about just
you know monetary policy and the issues
at hand and what is the right solution
but yes to your other point i definitely
think
you know when you talk about um the left
side of it the democrats like they
definitely um
it's kind of yeah the more control they
have the better in a way right so that's
and that's where bitcoin differs because
bitcoin
stands for freedom right
self-sovereignty taking responsibility
for
you know where you like just store your
wealth the keys component of it how are
you what are you using for custody like
there's responsibility in that but
that's the beauty of it
as well and
it's yeah i i i could definitely see how
that's gonna be some
hurdle to get over um politically so
so you put your so did you end up
actually putting your entire salary into
bitcoin is that what happened
yeah so the the crazy story on that is
uh
two or three weeks after that i end up
getting released so
um right now what does that mean you
ended up getting released
release meaning i got um cut from the
chiefs at the time
so you're gonna have to give more i know
so um
remember i'm not american um so
usually there's so there's 90 guys on a
roster initially in the off season right
and then you'll work to 53. usually that
that
they cut down from 90 to 53 from august
and camp which has always been the case
um for me i've actually never been
released or cut is the terms that we use
and three weeks after that decision i
end up getting
cut or released so i wasn't on the team
of the chiefs so
when it comes to salary it's um i mean i
was getting paid already at the time
the the the the checks in the offseason
uh no i was getting a bitcoin at the
time so i already said you were
getting paid in bitcoin yeah i was
getting paid in bitcoin but not just the
complete salary that i would have
during the season so that's you know it
was terrible so um
but that's definitely the plan has never
changed and nor will it it's um
you know for me it's i i just you know
understand
the the game and the risk associated
with it and
i kind of just looked at my situation um
and the injuries that i've had and the
the risk of
injury going forward and and that was
simultaneously
you know that thought was happening as i
was exploring bitcoin on a deep level so
then for me
it was like well how do i optimize if
i'm trying to optimize in every
you know facet of my life like how do i
do it in compensation
and especially given the risk physically
that my occupation demands
and that's where it was like man get
paid in bitcoin
so for me if i'm you know when i'm
playing i want to get paid 100 of my
salary in bitcoin
like that has never faltered it's
actually increased over time because
it's funny
you know that gosh it's been a little
over two months at this point
but i look at like just my
the increase in my education and
understanding of bitcoin now just
compared in just two
two months time it's crazy how much more
i know now
what do you feel like you've learned in
two months
it's definitely so uh initially it was
definitely looking at like from a macro
perspective what was happening fiscally
and monetarily
and just the upside right the sound
money component
and a big part of me wanting to do it
too was i was getting
really just you know fed up and
frustrated with friends and peers saying
well
i missed it right i missed bitcoin uh
yeah i need to go
i need to go buy a doge
they told you to buy those oh no no
they're saying or something cheaper
right
anything that's cheaper because that
means better value right like it makes
it doesn't make sense like that thinking
so yeah
if you think like that you probably just
haven't done the research right let's be
honest so
were they telling you to buy like shiba
inu no no one tell me no one told me it
was telling me anything it was more so
just as i started to talk about
my um understanding of bitcoin and my
passion for it
a lot of people like oh yeah for sure
for sure but i missed it man
it's crazy i missed it i'm too late like
i gotta i gotta
go you know do some other altcoin that's
cheaper
so for me i looked at it as
okay it makes the most sense to optimize
for me in my life
my convictions at a level where i want
to get paid 100 my salary in bitcoin
but then also it was an opportunity to
be like hey i'm a dca bitcoin through
2022. it's not you're not late
like like long term we'll look back and
see that it was the right decision i
understand
there's price action in the in the
intermediate that's
going up and down and people see think
i'm a genius and then also an idiot
right
i'm cool with that because i understand
the long term vision
my time preface is extremely low and
so that was that was definitely um the
initial
you know thinking and then lately it's
been the morality kind of in the
virtuous components of bitcoin
right um
um sound money kind of things that we've
talked about earlier on in this episode
just on
how it could be um you know hope for
you know other countries it's not just
americans it's it's everywhere it's
billy conan's hope for everybody and
here's why
and i just it felt it kind of just
um fell in line with my my principles
and the way my moral compass on just
what i believe to be you know providing
to the world
your energy your economic contributions
your resources and your value to get
paid in something
that and it's okay to save too like we
shouldn't be punished to save
like if you look at history you know
just from the primitive
ages like you know we we we developed
because
we saved we stored food for when we
didn't know what would happen tomorrow
and that is that is um
something to be protected right property
rights and so that's been like the
latest kind of deep dive for me
and at the same time as i'm going
through that it was so cool to see
you know el salvador obviously and this
following the bitcoin
convention with jack mullers and what
happened there and which is cool too
because i did a mission trip my senior
year
or my junior year of high school to el
salvador oh wow
yeah it was actually funny because
somebody i think i
i have tweeted it was like you know just
a reminder
you know el salvador chose bitcoin not
doge and people were like i swear
you know these bitcoin maxis don't know
anything about salvador and they're just
using this opportunity they don't
know anything about it and i at the time
i've been i've been
well yeah i i just went up from miami to
tampa to see my family
and i was like hey jackass so glad i was
able to stop home
uh put on like my el salvador jersey
that i got and this kind of told him
everything how i've been
there and saw the need for it and how
people could benefit and the people it
was a
funny moment yeah no that is really cool
yeah i mean
everyone's gonna trash you online no
one's gonna love you um
no people will love you but they'll hate
you as well um but yeah so
you make a really interesting point
actually about saving so this is my
thing okay
i feel like we live in this um hyper
consumer-centric society where everybody
is just
buying and buying to get their next you
know kick of happiness
that sort of short time gratification
and
i feel like the volatility encourages
you to bloody well
save you know like i get paid on bitcoin
as well
and i was getting paid at sixty thousand
dollars when bitcoin was literally at
its peak
right so i've now lost fifty percent
of my money and people are like oh
you're gonna sell
no like i have to save now like i have
to save
because i because i obviously believe
that it's going to go
back up i believe it's going to go to
500 000 eventually even probably 1
million in the next 15 years
um i wholeheartedly believe that
otherwise i wouldn't dedicate my entire
career to it sure
um so but it but it teaches you to save
because
i can't sell that i can't sell that
bitcoin now otherwise i'm going to take
a serious hit yeah you can't you can't
yeah you can't do that
it's um yeah yeah you're right like how
could you then it's
it completely defeats the purpose it's
it's something that yeah is a long-term
play
it's uh unfortunately yeah we live in a
consumption-driven economy
and the the people just want short-term
gratification right and
um i see that in my industry right where
i mean guys are making life-changing
money a game right
a game would be making what some people
maybe get in a lifetime can you give me
an idea like
what is like an average i mean on
average
i mean i don't know how to say that's a
good question i don't know what the
average salary is i know i've been
league minimum all of my career i think
people sometimes link the nfl logo to
this everyone's a multi-millionaire that
was something that was unique about my
story too was my conviction is i'm not
just this guy that's paid and i'm just
okay i'll do this you know yolo to the
moon like it was no this is something
that aligns with
what i believe in um it was just a
significant part of my wealth
but yeah i mean i would say on average
people probably make
i don't know probably a couple million a
year because if you look at the average
the median maybe not but like definitely
the average is probably like
you know you can make 200k a game
potentially
maybe like some guys are gonna make you
know 25 million in a year as a
quarterback you know that's like a
million a game
you have guys making probably three to
four what might be the average maybe
um but then the bulk of the league is
league minimum
i think at least i think at least
forty percent of the league is um
undrafted free agents correct don't
don't you know hold me to that
i wasn't quite um but yeah i think and
that's kind of what the more i thought
like how
man as long as you're being smart with
your money and you can cover your
short-term expenses
like the risk reward of the game and
what we're getting paid as league
minimum
i thought wow the need for bitcoin is
even higher for those individuals
like myself and how long term you'll see
wow i didn't just get paid league and
league minimum i got paid a lot more
like i know it's so easy to say
looking back you know oh if i would have
bought right five years ago how much
money
especially with the growth that big wins
had but i do think i think
i would have i think after taxes i think
i ran the numbers just using the average
price over like the
the season the daily price um i think it
would have been like
seven million dollars more than just
being paid in fiat
and and then you just keep going down
that and that's kind of what led me to
my point earlier where if you have a
significant
you know significant amount of your
wealth and cash than the more need
for bitcoin that you need like i i
couldn't imagine going through 2020
sitting in cash and i know so many
athletes
that just whether they have
advisors or this themselves zetas hold
cash they hold cash and they put money
in risky
venture capital and p e deals that
typically don't pay out and
fixed income that's paying negative real
yields
and have expenses that exceed
their income and then they stop playing
and then they continue that lifestyle
and then that's why 78 of nfl players go
broke within three years
really yeah i didn't know that 78
percent did you say
yeah roughly i won't quote you again
yeah i think you can honestly quote me
yeah it gets scared right because like
now i have a platform people just you
know
but yeah that was definitely it was
something that
it was a broke uh 30 for 30 um
doc that's a shame yeah it was talking
about athletes and
just basically the what i just explained
and i would like to think
you know since then we've been aware of
it and like to make better financial
decisions we're cutting expenses
deploying
capital smartly but let's say you save
as
we all know in this economic environment
if you're saving cash
then it's you're destroying wealth
right and you're making the american
dream that much harder sure you're
making a lot more money
but if you're looking at this
preservation of wealth it's all relative
to your individual circumstance right
like there's so many better ways to
optimize in this holding fiat
right now because savers are getting
punished like that is very clear
regardless if you believe in bitcoin or
not
holding cash is trash like i think
that's starting to become more
widespread which is also another reason
why i'm bullish on bitcoin adoption
as younger individuals are to speak
becoming aware of that and seeing okay
this isn't you know the best you know
solution for me i need to invest and
i look at the properties of bitcoin
versus
real estate fixed income and equities
and i still see
bitcoin being the better outcome yeah no
i'm with you i mean i think
no i no but i'm with you i think you
know
we live in a society whereby
inflation is a real problem and we're
not really taught about it
and i think that's really unfortunate
and
i think that you know the rich know that
you need to
invest invest in the stock market invest
in property whatever it is
and here's my thing i just feel like um
the average person doesn't understand
how on earth to do that
and for once we have something it's just
and it's so easy
and it just you know you can create real
wealth and
you know with inflation that we've seen
over the years i remember even like 10
years ago
having conversations about inflation and
and how my generation won't be able to
get on the property ladder and you know
all this stuff that your grandparents
were and
this whole conversation and i just feel
like we finally have something like we
have
something to not make us feel so um so
screwed
by the system um but that's really
interesting what you said about the
players
um i actually had no idea that around 78
did you say yeah that was the latest out
that i saw
it could be um dated some um hopefully
it's better
but yeah yeah i think it was like 78 and
then i think it's maybe 60 percent for
nba athletes
because they make they make quite a bit
more um
it is so but do you um
given you're now super in love with
bitcoin
i was gonna say bitcoin maximalist
because i haven't asked you about that
yet i don't know how you feel about the
rest of the space
um but given you know you found bitcoin
and you're happy and everything
do you have plans to educate your
teammates other players have you tried
um have you had much backlash yeah no
that's
i mean that's my passion uh yeah
obviously i have a uh
a great opportunity with athletes
because that's where i have connections
with that's where
yeah that's my friend group right that's
who i've operated with and
been an athlete you know professionally
for five years college since 2012
it's my life and there's a huge need for
it
and but anybody like my passion is
making bitcoin simple
for all people to understand it but yes
athletes for sure that's definitely
so i always you know as we said earlier
you know when i was studying thinking
wall street and then when i got in the
league it was like okay do i want to go
work that
type of life maybe it's just you know
i'm analytical but also leveraging the
personality and just being able to
communicate with people and maybe like
you know being a financial advisor for
athletes
and as i've you know understood bitcoin
more
it's been okay what's the need for how
can i
basically combine all of it the
intersection of professional sports
finance and bitcoin what is the overlap
and that's where one of the plans for me
like this
your internet is cutting out yeah i'm
not sure if it's me
i don't know if it's me if it's you
maybe you guys can let us know in the
comments if
sean cut out for you a bit or whether it
was me did you see me okay like did i
freeze
yeah no you you were fine okay oh you're
back anyway
yay okay where did you lose me
i kind of just i kind of just got the
whole this is your passion you're going
to help educate more people
um bring more people into sports and
then sorry bring more more of your
more of your fellow sports players into
bitcoin and then i lost you
yeah yeah so basically just you know
from my
history and what i kind of thought and
what i'm going to do now the overlap of
football or professional sports finance
and bitcoin how can i given my
understanding and my knowledge and
passion for it
help other athletes help people and
just explain to them the idea simply and
provide resources and just be an aid and
preserving their wealth like that's my
passion
and it's exciting and yeah it's like a
humanitarian mission
yeah yeah it really is it's like i
definitely want to
just my next career whatever that is
like football obviously was um there's
so many opportunities to
whether speaking engagements or doing a
camp and being a light for kids to you
know be a mentor and show
like by example like you know the
dedication and sacrifice and work ethic
needed to
be successful successful in sports but
you know beyond that it doesn't
necessarily check the box like
you know what i want to do next like
whenever that happens right it's like i
want to do something that isn't for
money
it is because i'm making an impact
positively on the world
and eventually the money will follow
that based off the value that i
bring um wait so this is what i was
going to ask you though wait let me just
jump in because
this whole conversation i've noticed you
have a mentality
um which is i i need to have something
something after you know whether it's in
case of um
physical injury so you've got your
finance degree
um you know whatever it is you're always
thinking ahead which is super smart so
once you know say your body's tired
no more no more nfl um
uh what what do you want what's the goal
what would you like to do because
clearly you have quite an
entrepreneurial mindset
you have a humanitarian goal what do you
want to do
yeah you're still you know you're you're
like you're like 28. yeah i'm 20 yeah 28
so i'm young yeah yeah
28. um but yeah like
we to what we said like it wasn't it's
not a plan b right because
it's playing plan a doesn't work if you
have a plan b but
you can definitely it's an excellent
utilize you can utilize they're
the same in my eyes they've all they've
always been the same i've used football
to
get free education i've used football to
expand my network and have an
opportunity maybe to
get opportunities on wall street that
maybe when it come to
a person that just you know didn't go to
an ivy league school
um it's there's definitely been
transferable skills
and be a professional athlete that apply
to any industry
but yeah like i know if you look at
history anyone that thinks you're just
going to play forever
and hopefully you play enough to be
financially set and then you can really
just work on the humanitarian
component of it but that doesn't happen
for every athlete
and you know to our early point
unfortunately
even guys that make millions of dollars
they still are not set because of
the the lifestyle that they live so
what's the overlap it's it's again it's
pr um
it's just allowing them to be
financially free
and preserve their wealth and
just be a resource for them in education
and provide the resources to do that
right and i think that the best
uh investment vehicle is through bitcoin
and yeah so my next endeavor
yeah it's definitely gonna be something
surrounding bitcoin like i said earlier
it was always something
that had to do with you know wanting to
be a financial advisor
but it's like i can still do that and
then now introduce
bitcoin within the exposure within the
portfolio because now at this point
given everything that's happening
the infrastructure the politics get
involved the amount of money the upside
just look at what's happened
if you don't have exposure it's not
you're not doing your fiduciary standard
in my opinion
to your clients by not at least having
some percentage of your wealth
allocated towards bitcoin and it's all
based off risk
and current expenses and what their just
financial picture
their mosaic looks like would kind of
dictate
how much exposure they have to bitcoin
right and
i'm passionate about that and i know
that there's definitely something next
and if it's
you know like you said i do have an
entrepreneurial mindset and if it's
not that then it's falling in line with
a company
that i will just go through oh sorry i
don't want to close right now but go
through a brick wall
you know yeah yeah that that leader that
ceo that founder
almost like a players coach the coaches
that i've had as an
athlete like i know the difference
between somebody that's a dictator that
just doesn't bring out the best in you
or somebody that's like
man you check the box and everything
that i would want to do and you have
some opportunity that
i can provide value to let's go do this
and wake up every single day with that
mindset so yeah it's it's i'm not you
know
that's probably that's all the thought
that's been towards it because
i'm a professional athlete all my most
of my time and resources go to being
ready to play on sundays
but yeah whenever it does and that's
next for me for sure i'm excited about
it too because it's
how could you not be i mean look at you
you get to do this every single day i'm
sure you're ecstatic
every day right yeah i love it i mean
for me it's just it's just game changing
um like i i have this thing where i
don't like to follow hierarchies i don't
like to follow i don't like to fall into
line
um i'm very much um my own person
and i love what i do so much because it
means that i can do what i want on my
own terms
and bitcoin has allowed that um at such
a young age as well you know
um when if i compare where i'm at to
where
some of my peers are at from school um
it you know it's it's worlds apart um
and bitcoin has
allowed that this whole industry has
allowed that um
i like i said earlier you know i think
like the climate right now is
the geopolitical climate is just
absolutely nuts with all these lockdowns
and everything and
you know bitcoin for me is just like so
i find so much comfort
you know and so much peace and the fact
that like you can really opt out of a
system like there is something
you know and we've got cbdc's coming um
and i think they're gonna be awful
they're going to be
terrible and they're going to have a
whole marketing campaign behind them
and this is this is
i don't know it's it's really really
cool and i i say to my mum
like all the time i say i'm so blessed
i'm so happy i'm so grateful
to be at the forefront of this
revolution
um because it's it's in line with
everything you know i believe in
yeah absolutely i'm blessed to say the
same
and be kind of the earlier pioneers
within the athletics
um spell you know the space and
but also there's so many good people
that's what i've realized too this in
this time like
even leading up to miami but then after
it's like the amount of great people
that i've met
it's so crazy like the smartest
individuals and the ones that want to do
good for the world
it just seems inevitable that you
eventually
spend time and go down the rabbit hole
yeah
and just get it and once you see it you
can't unsee it right and it's been
really
cool uh to experience that and i'm
excited to
you know continue doing that yeah that's
the thing especially because you end up
meeting so many like-minded people and
it's so refreshing
because you know your mentality can be
of a certain way and you don't
understand why
the people around you don't see the
world the way you do and then you find
this community and everybody
is so driven and sort of sees things the
same way so
yeah it's it's it's truly amazing and i
absolutely love what you're doing i love
that you've got this plan you know
after it's the humanitarian mission you
know i really respect it so
i want to thank you so much sean it's
been such a pleasure um i've honestly
learned so much about you from you
your mission and i think i think it's so
great before we head off
um do you have any last final words
uh no just you know thank you so much
for having me it's been awesome to
tell my story and people can find me at
caulking22 on twitter
and yeah no it's just i'm blessed for
the opportunity
and just do your own research that's
what i tell everybody that's what
inspired me to make my decision if i
could just
you know cause somebody to sit down and
spend an hour or two
and not just reading headlines and
formulating opinions based off that
like really distinct for yourself um
that's it right and then match your
conviction you know with how much money
you have in it
and just go from there totally with you
sean thank you so much
it's been such a pleasure thank you
everyone for watching
and thank you to my sponsors blockfy
luna and
compass mining we will see you all next
week bye bye
[Applause]